What comes to mind when you think about success and productivity?
For me, like probably most people today, the first thing that comes to mind are the
billionaires and entrepreneurs that are household names.
I mean, clearly, they must be doing something right with their their time if they “made
it this in far life.”
But of course, that’s because our world today defines success based on fame and wealth.
The more money you want, the more productive you must be.
I’d like to think that, as Muslims, we can agree that our lives are not defined
by these goals.
And before we talk about tips to implement good habits, we’ve got to reorient the purpose
we’re here for.
One of the most powerful sayings of the Prophet (saw) that really captures not simply our
purpose in life, but the direct and immediate role Allah (swt) has in facilitating our affairs
is one in which he states: Man kanat al-akhiratu hammahu, that the person who make the
next life their primary concern--hammahu--their goals, their desires, ja’al Allahu ghinahu fi qalbihi, Allah (swt) will
place wealth or abundance in their hearts, wa-jama’a lahu shamlahu, and He will organize this person’s
affairs, wa-atathu al-dunya wa-hiya raghima--and this world will come to them whether it-- here meaning the
world--wants to or not.
This is incredibly profound because it puts our lives into so much perspective.
When we revolve our decisions and actions around the intention and the constant goal of pursuing
God’s pleasure in the next life, all of the doors of this world will open right
before your eyes.
Allah promises us that the world--no matter how corrupt we humans make it--the world will still
come to you, the believer seeking everything but the world.
Wa jama’a lahu shamlahu--such an incredible promise.
Translating it as “Allah will organize this person’s affairs” doesn’t do this statement justice.
Imagine an endless list of tasks that you have to get through.
Some are work related, some family, some personal.
Some need hours of attention, while others require running countless errands.
When the Prophet (saw) says that Allah will jama’a lahu shamlahu, it means that all of
those endless tasks, that seemed scattered and require so much time, will effortlessly come together.
And you’ll suddenly find yourself accomplishing multiple tasks quickly and with ease.
In other words, the person who keeps their eyes on the prize and truly defines their
life based on the purpose they were created for, will not only be blessed in their
time and work, but most importantly, ja’ala Allahu ghinahu fi qalbihi--Allah will fill their heart with
a sense of abundance, accomplishment, and true fulfillment that very few people in this world experience.
The hadith, however, doesn’t stop there.
On the flip side, we learn of the consequences of those whose sole focus in this
world--the intention behind which they build their goals and habits--is in pursuit of this world alone,
and the fame and riches it offers.
Allah says in regard to these people, they will only ever get exactly what has been
decreed for them--no more, no less.
Meaning that they are entirely deprived of any form of barakah--or blessing in one’s time, efforts,
health, family, you name it.
And on top of that, farraqa aw shattata alayhi shamlahu, their affairs will be scattered.
Think back again to that endless list of tasks you need to accomplish.
Think of each task as a paper stacked on your desk.
You’ve got a pile to get through.
When the Prophet says that Allah will scatter their affairs, imagine that huge pile of papers
on your desk flying in the wind and scattering in every direction.
You’re then left running to chase after each task, making everything that much harder and more
time consuming. And at the end of the day, the one who is looking only to
find happiness in this world, ja’ala Allahu faqrahu bayna aynayhi--that Allah will stamp poverty, a lack
of success, that sense of emptiness, between that person’s eyes.
Which is to say that, such a person, no matter how hard they try, will never
gain a true sense of accomplishment in this world.
Real achievement is far from the lives of the multi million and billionaires we are so
familiar with today.
Our lives have meaning so much greater than that, and only by living in hopes of
fulfilling our true purpose will we experience our peak productivity and success.